i want to show you
a perfect example of why
i am leaving the dystopian nightmare of
california and moving to the free
state of florida ron desantis who is the
governor of florida who is a good decent
man trying to fight the tide of nonsense
and authoritarian lunacy that is
sweeping across this country he is
fighting to keep his state free and i'm
going to damn well do everything i can
to help him well he was on laura
ingram's show last night talking about
the stark difference
between california and florida and i'm
fairly certain he was talking directly
to me through the tube take a look
really quickly on this issue
of mask mandates i know you've rejected
them across the board
what's your reaction tonight to both
newsome and california and hoco in new
york going back to mass mandates
with this omicron which seems to be
thankfully so far
a mild virus
and that's the data we have at least so
far on that what's your
what's your reaction to the blue states
reaction to uh to this
well what are we on like day 700 of the
15 days to slow the spread the fact of
the matter is i think we've learned you
give these people an inch they will
never let go they're going to take a
mile they are going to restrict they're
going to mandate they're going to lock
you down and we cannot accept that
obviously in florida we do not accept it
so there's no reason to be restricting
or mandating anybody
throughout our country and the fact that
this is still going on in these blue
states and may even intensify over the
coming weeks and months
it just shows you if you value your
freedom
in 2022 if you're in those states you
need to make your voice heard and you
got to do a change of direction because
i fear that they're going to continue to
do this until they suffer at the ballot
box yeah new york has now a higher case
rate
than florida governor new york city new
york city just to be specific about that
yeah and so here's the thing laura it's
a seasonal pattern southern states have
a different season the northern states
have they're going through their season
mandates and restrictions have not been
effective but they've been very costly
and i think the proof is in the pudding
you have people that want to come to
florida to vacation buy homes you don't
have the opposite where people are
leaving free states to try to go to new
york or some of these other places
god i can't wait to get out of here yeah
everything he said there is true how
refreshing is it these days to hear
someone that plainly speaks the truth
that doesn't want to rule over you that
just wants to create the conditions so
that the people that live in his state
can live free that mandates don't work
that we know all of this nonsense
lockdowns don't work you can keep people
in masks forever it's seasonal and it's
gonna be like the flu and some people
will get a little sicker and some people
won't and will get hurt immunity and all
of those things it's just plain spoken
truth i cannot wait to get out of here
can you guys feel it yeah yeah i'm
i'm literally gonna explode the end of
this show is just me spontaneously
combusting and then they'll just take my
mush to
florida oh my god and by the way
desantis he's lost a little weight which
that kind of hints at perhaps a
presidential run could that be i feel
like they always try to get fit right
before a presidential run which speaking
of that i saw a picture of uh of trump
on the golf course a day or two ago it
looks like he's lost like 40 pounds so
who knows what's going on